chip is retired but yeah I understand
what you're saying okay I was gonna ask
you for an update today anyway on that
there's no update as we're talking about
successful radio shows well it's I mean
yesterday he was posed I
he wasn't retired he was on hiatus yeah
today is he retired are still on hiatus
whatever it is it's it's I'm just I'm
not gonna do it how come it's not want
to yeah it's just it's for what I'm just
I don't want to do it my Rogan is up
today - I did Roby when I was out in LA
so that oh that's amazing I think that
went up today so it should be up and I
think it's up you didn't try to get chip
on Rogan no I don't think I could do
that I don't even if first I don't know
if Joe would do it Joe's - Joe's too
rational and like he might enjoy it for
a few minutes but then he probably like
what am i doing
yeah this is the biggest podcast in the
country when we talk for three hours
he's just it's a conversation right it's
it's it's it ebbs and it flows and it's
about everything it's known him for
decades and over like he's looking at
you going like why I meant Jim that's
what we started talking I think that's
how we started talking this about you
realize how long he's known is I think
my first memory of him doing gates the
other was 1992 doing a [ __ ] gig in
like upstate New Jersey somewhere some
like a packer
so it's weird like when you realize how
long you know a guy for to sit there
yeah and go what are you [ __ ] wrestle
you know would just be weird it would be
really without somebody else there yeah
maybe for an hour maybe you could do
like the MMA show that he does or
something like that for an hour yeah but
for three hours to sit I'd be humiliated
yeah it would be embarrassing I couldn't
do it
you think he would break in three hours
I would yeah because with two people it
would be too bizarre to have that kind
of conversation if there was other
people there like if Anthony was there
and one of the Pearl I were you we're
[ __ ] Bobby like then at least people
can bounce off and what here's you know
what that is
it's a validation of the character we'd
be there to validate
don't worry yes this is stupid we're
here with you yeah it's a real person if
nobody's there with you it's like I'm
alone and why am I doing this stupid
what am i doing oh my god I still have
two glasses on why am i yeah how come
Jim Norton doesn't blink when he's in
character Jim pointed that out she
pointed that out yet
tami-lynn time the only time I don't
blink you so I'm doing him see my
[ __ ] the faces I'm all over the place
so chip is still doing cameos for now
yeah and I'm not being Leedy trying to
get enjoy I just you think chip might
leave show business for a period of time
you know there's no doubt it's a hundred
percent trip is going to leave show huh
I love that we will we will have to say
goodbye to chip is going to leave public
life at some point yeah yeah maybe you
she's maybe chips should try to garner
sympathy and jump on this and say he has
lung cancer I didn't want to have to
tell you this in a shitty home studio
I got piles I don't know where to find
it behind the scenes person who's really
good at getting everything together and
it's like it you can't you can't give
him a ton of money because there's not a
ton of money cuz you got a ton of money
to be made this is just not at this
point that's the thing about it like
it's serious we have this amazing staff
around us but that's because serious has
a ton of money coming in and serious can
pay him we don't have to pay him out of
our pockets right when you're doing a
podcast you should make enough money on
the podcast where you can pay people to
do a good job or
you just gotta do it yourself and that
becomes really a lot it's hard between
radio and UFC and personal life stuff
yeah we all have a certain again this is
a great easy job but you know you only
have so much time to [ __ ] to do [ __ ]
and then it's like getting people
together and then okay can we do a live
show hey is this guy available are you
available can you travel ah should we
all get hotels it's just a whole [ __ ]
thing you know it's just too much and to
what degree is other stuff suffering be
like what's that what's the value of
this thing that I'm doing and what's it
costing me in terms of time and energy
and I love it chip is the most fun I
have but it's just the other stuff that
round they feel a certain way but go on
no it's even more fun than being Jim
Norton there's nothing personal okay I
enjoy doing chip with you but I mean I
like other targets chip that I said I'm
so sick of it I'm just sick of the whole
of you or chip or